tonight's lecturer Keith from Oh
become weedy is I've never got a ride
Keith gun whitey weedy Keith will speak
tonight is associate professor and
assistant dean in our school professor
Kay received his Bachelor of
architecture art degree in architecture
from the University of California at
Berkeley and his Master of Architecture
from sci-arc the Southern California
Institute of architecture after sci-arc
he worked in the Los Angeles office of
Smith Miller and Hawkinson in 1996 he
joined the faculty at the Rice
University School of Architecture where
he remained until joining us at Yale in
2003 where he has combined teaching in
both the core and advanced studios with
provocative seminars devoted to close
readings of important figures in recent
architecture such as the critic Reyner
Banham
and the architect James Stirling
professor Kay's independent written and
design research has revealed pivot to
hidden organizational patterns in what
is too frequently called and all too
cavalierly dismissed as suburban sprawl
the Artic author of articles and reviews
he most recently published the article
trip freedom land in the journal
30-60-90 freedom land is the topic of
tonight's talk please join me in
welcoming our associate professor Keith
from whitey
following is talk because the gallery is
being reinvested reinstallation for the
Gwathmey Segal exhibition following the
talk this evenings reception will be at
the top of the stairs to my right in the
novel drawing studio Keith thank you Bob
I'd also like to thank my friends and
colleagues on the faculty and the
students here at Yale particularly those
who've taken or should I say suffered
through my gross domestic product course
which is directly related to the
material I'll talk about tonight I also
want to thank ed etre is at site
Magazine perspective and 30-60-90 where
some of this material has been published
or will be published 30-60-90 will come
out later this month and finally I'd
like to thank the Whitney Humanities
Center for sponsoring some of this work
with a Whitney Griswold faculty research
grant so tonight I will talk about
freedom land but at the end of what
Peter has told me needs to be at less
than one our talk so I'm gonna be
gunning through maybe parts of this but
generally I'll be speaking about an
obsession of mine the American
single-family house my talk will be
presented in four parts
beginning with the first-hand accounts
of visiting a new home center during the
go-go housing years of the early aughts
next I'll discuss the actual design of
some of the home builder houses
presenting six plan types that have
identified in my research and then I'll
spend REM cool houses typical plan essay
into a reflection the consequences of
the American fascination with the house
finally I'll briefly show a project
that's currently occupying my thoughts
and time Freedomland
to begin I'd like to briefly summarize
the housing events of the past decade
slide please and this is for Joel cockin
so a graph the last one you'll see the
green line is the earnings per share for
KB home from 1998 to 2009 and the red
line is the size and megabytes of their
annual reports over that same time
period so I think that's a pretty good
history of the last ten years
economically of the house
so right there I've cut about five
minutes out of my talk since we all know
what happened and what continues to
happen we're essentially in the fifth
year of an ongoing housing depression
recession but really we're in a housing
depression so while the story of the
housing boom is one of them pressing it
in numbers it's also one of human
actions and artifacts and meshed in a
web of economic political and cultural
forces in this sense the story of design
and the aspirations it serves so rather
than talk about the numbers I'd prefer
to talk about the houses in addressing
the subject I've tried to suppress any
aesthetic concerns or moral ones in
order to really see what was being built
and how it was being sold and delivered
the image of sameness and uniformity
that comes to mind when thinking about
merchants built houses does not
necessarily hold true when one gets out
on the cul-de-sac this is a slide of
David Weekley court you'll notice that
the garages have landscaping in front of
them these are model homes behind a
big-box store off highway 290 in Houston
Texas in 1997 David Weekley entered the
big-box game with his new home center
17,000 square foot superstore this quote
one-stop home shop turned the superstore
concept inside out it sold not only the
goods that go in the houses but the
houses themselves David Weekley
positioned his superstore to be a
category killer like its big-box
neighbors the new home center
capitalized on their innovations adding
personal service to customer choice and
competitive prices design quote to
service the needs of customers from
start to finish
end quote it incorporates almost every
conceivable component of the home buying
process a map room of weekly communities
on-site model homes that you see here a
showroom of finishes and fixtures and
even a mortgage and title company to
assist in financing and closing the deal
combination of service and selection
generates an atmosphere of exclusivity
by offering an apparently customized
experience and weekly is not alone
almost every major home builder has a
home center or a series of home centers
in major markets and do all of those
things that weekly does home buyers can
choose from over 1,000 floor plans and
through consultation with the weekly
designer quote personalize their home in
one of over 25 different subdivisions
with hundreds of design options and
thousands of decorator selections this
subdivision happens to be at the home
center after selecting a home plan
buyers meet their designer to finalize
finishes and fixtures in our assigned a
personal builder trademark term who
supervises construction of their custom
home buyers can also check construction
status daily via personal
password-protected website marketing
offers the consumer and entire
philosophy of living at the home center
the homes are presented as the product
of over quote 20 years of research into
how you live life design this is going
to drive me a little crazy also
trademarked as weekly is according to
sales literature quote in art a science
a unique ingredient in each home we
build that enhances its value life
design spins David Weekley product out
of the ordinary cycles of suburban
marketing and into the world of custom
construction ensuring quote that your
home will live as well as it looks the
sales experience transforms a more or
less typical suburban home into an
innovative design
achieved through incomparable choice
with inspired service that's weeklies
talk not mine
the buyer is not just personally a house
purchasing a house but a perfectly
crafted and carefully marketed lifestyle
but the real magic of david weeklies big
box is that it's not really a box at all
it's a cul-de-sac where the weekly sales
slogan we offer homes and lifestyles is
brought to life just behind the home
center you'll find this court on its at
three ideal homes that demonstrate just
how david weeklies designs become buyers
dreams each home is styled or more
precisely life styled to show the
advantages of purchasing a weekly home
these are the plans the actual plans of
the three houses on that court and
really you're mostly going to see plans
in this talk in a variety of forums
so now we're going to go in a little
tour through these model homes which are
designed down to the last detail the
smallest the Wilkins the one on the
lower right is relatively modest by
Houston standards one-story two baths
three bedrooms plus flex space the
Wilkins not-so-subtle French themed blue
and yellow carries through to the
color-coordinated socks and shirts
hanging to dry in the laundry room in
the kitchen prints of a Parisian street
scene lined the walls in a cookbook
entitled backroad bistros farmhouse fair
lies open near wicker bread basket
overflowing with baguettes the Wilkins
is not the smallest plan in weeklies
arsenal in fact at approximately 2,200
feet it's almost 600 feet larger than
something called the East Ale but the
Wilkins is clearly the starter home in
this ideal homes trio the furnishings
and household belongings suggest the
homes fictional family is a young couple
with an infant and a toddler the
smallest bedroom is furnished as a
nursery stuffed animals fill the crib
and a changing table is stocked with
Huggies the second bedroom a little
girls houses Patsy's puppet Playhouse
with the puppet actors hung from the
theater ceiling and an audience of dolls
on the bed the flex space is certainly
the young father's domain at least until
another child comes along the room is
outfitted with fishing poles nuts
aquatic taxidermy and fishing related
prints on the desk sits a flat screen
computer by props an electronics company
that reduces overhead by dispensing with
circuitry the master bedroom or the
owner's retreat as it is known in most
current residential developers plans is
least distinguished by any character
traits except of course a taste for the
good life the food tray with the plastic
fruit and croissant breakfast sits on
the king-size bed clearly this is just
the beginning for the Wilkins family the
second model on David Weekley court the
Collingsworth measures in at almost
2,900 square feet it cost anywhere from
a modest 194,000 to an upcharge 408 site
up charged 485,000 custom classic at
Cole's crossing described his quote and
exit from the fast lane where the
milkman still delivers and in fact at
the time of my visit
buyers did receive six months of free
milk delivery a step up from the Wilkins
the house introduces the increasingly
popular children's retreat between
bedrooms two and three it describes it's
described as a special place just for
the kids where they can do their
homework play games or watch TV while
mom and dad enjoys in quiet time with
the movie our reading by the family
family room fire the room holds an easel
and several board games along with a
colorful array of kid-friendly furniture
the display model corresponds perfectly
with the ideal I idealized life of
weeklies literature the kids in this
house rung two on the ladder to domestic
bliss are slightly older than those at
the Wilkins and are starting to display
personality traits with their bedroom
furnishings the young girl in bedroom 3
is still obsessed with dolls while the
young boy in bedroom two was in the
midst of a politically correct
cowboys-and-indians phase his wallpaper
shows an integrated southwestern camp
with teepees and a chuck wagon
apparently the boy also dreams of
growing up to be David Weekley on his
desk beside a tomahawk and beneath the
Buffalo Bill poster sits a props
computer where the sales were play sales
report displayed on its frozen screen
according to the report props provides a
critical sales advantage to the home
seller for the past four quarters sales
of model homes with props have
outperformed those without the
Collingsworth flex base is an optional
attic room complete with dormers perhaps
the cowboy loving son shows at saloon
furnishings swinging doors saddle bar
stools cowboy boots a full-size John
Wayne cardboard placard and cartoon
cowboy wall covering several resin
filled foam topped beer mugs in a few
bowls of stale popcorn sit with unplayed
pans at the poker table it's as if a
neutron bomb erased all the occupants
without disturbing their domestic dreams
by now you feel as if you spying on some
strangely perfect Stepford families in
several rooms embroidered pillows
support clever sayings like if you want
the best seat in the house move the dog
my favorite thing to make for dinner is
reservations and of course I may have my
faults but being wrong is not one of
them the unseen weekly set decorator
seems to be asking how could anyone who
lives as well be wrong
the calling some Hollingsworth's may not
be wrong but they're also not as right
as their neighbours the Winchester
measures 3400 square feet in his price
as low as 227 thousand dollars the
biggest of the three homes the
Winchester still ranks a significant
notch below the biggest and most
expensive weekly home but among the
three ideal homes the Winchester
represents the top of the ladder
the ultimate and three steps to success
David Weekley new home center super
model series as you enter the winchester
you're greeted by the butler a flat
stiff Butler cut out of wood and painted
to resemble a servant from masterpiece
theater but a butler still he stands in
the foyer holding a serving tray with
four crystal brandy snifters with this
aristocratic flourish the scene is said
a dinner party is about to take place to
the left of the foyer the table is
carefully set and delicious looking
albeit artificial desserts are lined up
on the sideboard to the right dark
stained wood wainscoting and built-in
bookcases line the walls of the library
which features an antique drop front
writing desk in a crystal decanter
filled with both scotch
curiously Leon Eris's armageddon claims
a prominent place on the bookshelf has
weekly also imagined the bomb scenario
as well as in the other homes the
kitchen is the picture of good healthy
living several plastic artichokes
waiting to be prepared sit on the
cutting board freshly dried herbs dry on
her fresh herbs dry in Iraq and a can of
Ghirardelli coffee sits on the counter a
cornucopia overflows with wheat on the
island next to the range on the other
side of the spacious family room the
owners retreat is finished in the 19th
century French neoclassical style the
wallpaper shows a classical frieze and
carefully framed bows our prints hang on
the walls the breakfast tray rests on
the Ottoman complete with a fresh bowl
of plastic strawberries the plastic
Rahsaan and an empty coffee cap a photo
on the dresser shows smiling
grandparents with their three teenage
children through a corner window a
person relaxing in the city eric sitting
area could look out onto an overflowing
dumpster in the parking lot next door
the trash is conspicuously out of place
in this perfect world for a moment the
illusion is broken the three upstairs
bedrooms surround the wreck was a
children's retreat the retreat is
clearly the domain of teenagers the
board game Clue
is hidden away in a closet it's really
fascinating like these are their stuff
in closets everywhere in these houses
commanding far more attention a
bookshelf desk unit along the wall
displays what must be the complete props
product line a computer of stereo and
television the kids bedrooms in the
Winchester are the most fully developed
spaces in all of the ideal homes IDE
homes these children are ambitious and
hardworking with clearly defined dreams
and ambitions and not a trace of
adolescent ennemy bedroom 4 is the
romantic travelers room with model
biplanes sailing ships and hot-air
balloons
accompanied by a Victorian area painted
wooden figures in the closet - leather
suitcases await Duty bedroom - I really
wish these kids had names but they don't
bedroom - is the home of the future
archaeologists prehistoric looking
models of insects had booked on fossils
the globe and an African drum sit among
rattan furniture mosquito netting drapes
the canopy bed and the Raiders of the
Lost Ark poster hangs next to the door
the last room bedroom number 3 is at the
front of the house and belongs to a
young woman clearly obsessed with
architecture she appears a little
interested in the teenage trappings that
so annoyed ult's only a few - sultry
clippings of heartthrobs and a
homecoming ribbon are displayed on a
small tack board this young woman
focuses mainly on her goals a large wire
model of the Eiffel Tower stands next to
the bed framed photographs of classical
details hang on the walls along with the
surrealist montage of the interior of a
Gothic cathedral a slipcover of the on
the chair at the drafting table matches
a pattern Frank Lloyd Wright inspired
bedspread the shelves are stocked with
books on architecture along with oddly a
copy of Mommy Dearest assorted Frank
Lloyd Wright volumes keep company with
the book of late 20th century
skyscrapers a technical drafting book
and Diana aggressed architecture from
without a drafting a drawing tube sits
on the Shelf in the closet and nosy
shoppers who open the drawer next to the
desk will find a collection of drafting
supplies all of this is real more than
any other room in the idea homes at
David weeklies new home Center this last
one filled with architectural ambition
is the most strongly themed
moving through the homes on David
Weekley Court it is obvious how
carefully the domestic environment is
crafted to articulate a progression
through the three stages of a successful
at life in a successful family but this
last room the end of all the families
striving is confusing why is this
fictional young woman obsessed with
architecture when architecture is so
clearly not the issue in weeklies world
why not medicine or law something where
you can actually make a living because
as the British artist Richard Hamilton
once observed design is a sales weapon
the designer himself as a marketing aide
Hamilton argued the fact that someone
thought about the design of a product is
more valuable to the sales than the
product itself and David Weekley wields
his weapon well capitalizing on
architectures cultural cachet more than
architects do weakly distinguishes this
product from other special speculative
residential construction with the
marketing campaign that emphasizes the
company's design intelligence and
sensitivity at every turn with typical
immodesty the website's tastes life
design blends the fundamentals quote
life design blends the fundamentals of
design architecture engineering physics
psychology and sociology to create a
home that looks better and lives better
than all the rest and at the new home
center architecture a symbol of success
the symbol of success in one of market
capitalism ultimate luxury goods is made
available in a retail format the big box
superstore familiar to every American
shopper so needless to say I was
intrigued by weeklies very conscious use
of design and architecture to sell his
products and thought it might be
valuable to look at the architecture of
the houses not just the set design of
the model homes so the next phase of
this hopefully sub 60 minute talk is
called six typical plans and with this
project I analyzed the products of the
country's biggest home builders as
architecture the first findings that
I'll show tonight are the result of a
collection and comparative analysis of a
large catalogue of plans from high
production builders including weekly of
course but also kb home Lennar Ryland
Homes Toll Brothers Polti and others
the individual plan is used in the
marketing material disease builders maps
out an idea of domesticity of a possible
lifestyle for the consumer in critically
examining many plans however one can
identify evidence of an underlying set
of six basic types shown here for square
laminar cellular bisected nuclear and
branching used by the builders to
deliver levels of design to a wide range
of buyers these primary organizational
structures are complicated complemented
by the knowing and considered use of an
array of techniques including the
thickening of surface of walls the
exploitation of diagonal lines of site
and movement the scenographic layering
of spaces and the deployment of distinct
room shapes and profiles that's why I
would argue that only six basic types
define the Canon of contemporary
American production houses and a numeral
innumerable number of variations allow
that house to be marketed as a
customized product to a wide audience
these six types represent almost pure
versions okay
can I jump out of this quickly and then
back in I apologize now you're gonna see
how many slides are in hanging in free
cab but take these go really fast
this is the tiniest tiniest where's
fullscreen okay
these six types represent almost pure
versions of the six plan types that
define a taxon mate axonometric
structure of the American house the six
categories defined strategies for an
ideal type each of these is surrounded
by a soft circle of plans that
incorporate properties from other types
this chart graphs the path from a simple
four square over here to more complex
plans noting the overlaps along the way
average price per square foot increases
proportionally as you move from the
simple plan to the more complex plans on
that's your left your right following
the four square is the laminar and the
four square becomes a laminar in two
distinct ways either by elongation or by
widening an elongation the plan is
stretched out as rooms are added behind
the first floor spaces thereby producing
two long bars side by side the process
of widening occurs by adding spaces to
the sides of the house other bands
producing a plan composed of three or
more parallel strands cellular plans are
organized as a system of room to room
associations as here this gives a kind
of equivalence to the spaces that is
exemplified by the two axis symmetry of
the four square the cellular is an order
more complex than the four square but is
structured by similar principles nuclear
plans are often similar similar to the
cellular so here but defined by a
central space around which other spaces
are organized and often directly linked
the bisected plan here in this beautiful
neo Palladian version by Toll Brothers
distinguished by a central axis from the
front door through two primary formal
living space in the back
and finally branching plans essentially
are one of these other versions that has
gotten so big that you need to actually
build roads through to organize it and
connect back to the main and
here I'm going to quickly jump out and
back wasting time now we're gonna look
at a few of these okay so when I go
through each type in more detail this is
the four square typically modest in size
and often compact four squares ten
towards a tooth to floor arrangement
with roughly centered entrances clear
descendents of the traditional four
square home these plans are defined by
spaces of relatively equal size group of
two by two in a more-or-less square
formation as shown here in the Hartford
from beazer homes and here in plan 1806
from KB home in most contemporary
interpretations as in this plan one of
the quadrants is a garage this one
Ryland often an element in this case a
formal dining room usually found only in
larger more formal homes will be nested
into one of the quadrants you see that
right there
additionally here the house has been
further up scaled with oversized columns
at the entry massive columns
occasionally Foursquare organization can
be read in some plans even as the house
begins to swell and grow this plan the
Conrad from David Weekley exhibits a
super Foursquare order but is beginning
to resemble something more akin to a
lamina or even a cellular arrangement
you can sort of see when you actually
break down here so the blue are all the
bedrooms another thing to kind of watch
for is that the kind of I think very
intelligent way they create little
enclaves within the plan for different
private spaces one of the most commonly
utilized types laminar plans use a
layered formation of rooms and spaces to
create linear organizational strips the
layers can be quite regular with only
the simplest internal subdivision and
cross-grained circulation so here
the clearest example of this type extend
simply extend the bands Leighton in the
Foursquare either vertically as in the
Dublin or horizontally as in this plan
from KB home 2 & 3 bei versions of this
type of limited circulation between
between the strips thereby creating more
distinct zones within each band laminar
plans are often quite simple taking the
form of just two bands with a clear
linear boundary dividing them at a
narrow cleft and noting the entry other
laminar schemes are more complex in
terms of the number of layers sometimes
reading as in this weekly plan as a
classic center hall colonial with layers
added to one side to accommodate the
garage and in this case the ever more
common extra-large honors retreat which
is here this is the full owners suite in
the house and one last one super-sized
laminar plans this one courtesy of the
Toll Brothers tend to grow laterally
adding band after band as the number of
public rooms and garages accumulates in
a more in more high-end houses in its
accretion of rooms the plan also
suggests the next type which is the
cellular so here you see so it's vaguely
cellular that rooms just sort of a but
other rooms without dedicated
circulation except for the grand entry
hall here sprawling her compact cellular
plans are built for more or less
irregular clusters of rooms and other
spaces that are lined up along hallways
are joined directly one to another with
no immediately perceptible totalizing
order as in this plan this type can
produce the appearance the rooms piled
on top of rooms in which any clear
hierarchy between program and space is
obscured in its more compact form the
cellular type often verging on a laminar
structure can be used to create fairly
efficient plans still cellular schemes
are more typically found in large plans
with many rooms sorry a looser figural
envelope and drifting and disjointed
circulation like this one
although again like you know all of the
public space is being used to keep in
this case this might actually be two
master bedrooms which is also something
that's starting to happen in these
houses these plans almost never rely on
symmetry and rarely on overtly formal
planning strategies while cellular
cellular plans are an obviously unique
typed primarily due to the loose
room-by-room planning techniques they
often incorporate elements familiar from
other categories like the laminar in
this one vaguely laminar organization
that is one really long these are all
the same scale by the way all these
drawings this massive Toll Brothers plan
baguette betrays traces of the laminar
logic the previous one
while this plan by KB displays traits
familiar from both bisected schemes a
long entry hall that ends in a large
formal living room and it's beginning to
suggest a nuclear organization with the
central flex space and if you caught
that this is a flex space which really
can almost be anything in a house that
they can't figure out a new name for in
many cases I mean I don't know why this
isn't like the fabulous entry space but
it's the flex space so this begins to
actually become this is sort of leaning
towards the nuclear option which is this
these plans represent variations on the
nuclear scheme the first in the sequence
our old friend the Wilkins from David
Weekley Court closely approximates the
diagram in its pure form in this plan a
central element in this case the main
living room is surrounded by a perfect
ring of circulation off of which all
other spaces in the house are more or
less directly attached in this plan the
central space is the kitchen surrounded
again by a ring of circulation but
opening only to the family room at the
back of the house notice how the
bedrooms orbit the space each and its
own cluster I really I actually love
this like a family that doesn't really
get along
and the kids are actually sort of behind
a wall here this plan is similar but the
ring of circulation is incomplete
thereby creating a kind of private
cul-de-sac of bedrooms so these are all
along this dead-end although you can
always sneak out the garage in this plan
the circulation ring wraps the kitchen
and connects back through an open dining
nook this scheme demonstrates the kind
of blurring that occurs between and
across plan types it is in some ways a
bisected scheme which we have yet to get
to in which a central axis has been
displaced by the nucleus of the kitchen
and bisected plans the access through
the entrance in a dominant central
living space defines the main
organizational structure of the house
the most classical of the six type it
frequently produces symmetrical or
nearly symmetrical arrangements
often the bisected plan uses symmetry
and inflated proportions both outside
and in to generate a feeling of luxury
and wealth as in the malvern by Toll
Brothers this has obvious ambitions
toward Palladian grandeur using two
symmetrically arranged two-car garages
to frame a grand formal entry other
versions of the bisected plan lack the
grand gesture while retaining the
organizational principle of rooms and
spaces split by clear axial connection
from the front entry to a rear public
room often laminar in their basic
arrangement these plans often retain a
relatively compact perimeter
single-story bisected single-story
bisected plans sometimes employ a cross
axis here to further subdivide the
planet two distinct enclaves again these
kind of isolated private clusters in the
plan versions of the scheme can appear
nearly cellular in their planning but
are differentiated by the clear
separation of central space for
circulation and gathering purposes
finally the bisected plan can begin to
take on qualities of the final type the
branching plan does plan from envy homes
the Monticello and of course Virginia
shows the clear central axis from front
to back found in the bisected plan
but because of its strongly laminar
spatial order it adds a dedicated layer
of circulation that branches off from
the main axis to serve the other public
spaces the last of the six types
branching plans share a common
distinguishing feature of a dedicated
tree of circulation that originates at a
single source most typically the entry
to the house
this pattern accentuates lines of sight
and movement which in large floormat
floorplans can accentuate distances and
dramatize relationships between spaces
so you get and this is something you see
a lot of these plants too but most
commonly in this one the hypotenuse is
used to actually extend the kind of
perceived scale of the space looking
from corner to corner rather than
looking across at the opposite wall of
the box because they all after all still
mostly boxes although weekly like the
plans that are the weirdest are the
weekly plans just you know you could
start to pick them out if you looked at
them long enough branch it can also be
used to give a clear separation of
spaces to spaces and plan even as they
sometimes create disturbances at the
edge so here this room starts the
kitchen actually it's kicked out by some
of this internal activity in smaller and
more compact plans the line of
circulation along the hypotenuse of the
box increases the apparent scale of the
house so this is a pretty small house
but enter at the corner move across the
diagonal to the living spaces on the
opposite corner the house feels much
bigger most builders have plans based on
the scheme David Weekley loves it this
is his Kramer model and is most commonly
used to grand effect to organize larger
sprawling houses how am i doing on time
no okay good so we can do this what's
clear from this study is that while
there are if you believe my analyses six
basic underlying house types used by the
builders there is no real typical plan
and now I have to jump again so I
actually don't the jump that far back to
where we started there was no real
typical plan in thinking about this I
remember that REM coolhouse wrote a
piece called typical plan they published
in SML Excel in 1993 it was a
self-described meditation on the
American office building and by
extension the American Center City or
downtown I thought it might be
worthwhile to revisit that essay to see
if it post bubble revision might be in
order
atypical plans is the result published
in perspective forty three taboo it
shifts the focus of the American House
and by extension shifts the focus to the
American house and by extension the not
Center City or the suburbs and this you
could just read along if you'd like I
wish I had a bouncing ball to follow so
essentially what I did is I redacted a
lot of Colossus text and inserted new
text to sort of tell a story about the
American house and our dreams and
ambitions and why we're in the situation
we're in right now and you'll forgive me
I've been reading but now I'm going to
read some more atypical plans are an
American fabrication they are 360 degree
architecture architecture drunk on an
excess of space and resources they
belong to the new world the notion of
the atypical plan is disconcerting it is
the beginning in the end of
architectural history which is nothing
but the hysterical fetishization of the
prototypical plan atypical plans are
fragments of an acknowledged utopia
promises of a glorious architectural
past and a post architectural future
just as the man without qualities haunts
European literature the plan with
surplus quality surplus qualities is the
great achievement of American home
building in the mid nineteenth century
to the early 21st century there's an
American Century
half in which a typical plans developed
from the English country house with its
ruthless recreate ruthless creation of
luxurious domestic spaces of retreat
through the sheer multiplication of
rooms via early masterpieces of
accumulated space like the Alden house
its serially distinct rooms linked by
broad doorways its bays and turrets the
rambling expanse of its porches to
provisional combinations such as Charles
Moore's Klotz house of 1969 and Robert
AM Stern z-- Westchester House of 1974
together they represent evidence of the
discovery and subsequent mastery of a
new soon-to-be endlessly multiplied and
publicly traded architecture the
ambition of atypical plans is to create
new territories for the pleasurable and
profitable unfolding of old processes in
this case idealized accommodations for
domestic activities in an ownership
society but what is domesticity
supposedly the most primitive and
circumscribed circumscribed program it
is actually the most modern and mutable
domesticity makes conflicting demands
the architects of atypical plans
understand the secret of the business of
domesticity the house represents the
first totally absorptive program it
demands a particular but not a specific
architecture its function is both to
distinguish its occupants existence and
to signal their market participation
droven can invade any architecture
domesticity cannot within this
financially determined framework a
typical plans generate marketable
character Vincent Scully one of its
greatest chroniclers define the atypical
plan and the dreams attached to it with
bravura the massing has now become this
is a quote the massing has now become
complex and voluminous the interior
around its great fireplaces is no longer
a colonial box but a varied landscape of
its own it opens up to several levels
and pushes out two porches green
shadowed pavilions of permissive
relaxation of summer stock assignation
x' among cane chairs and the gliders
middle-class heaven heaven somnolent
with novels atypical plans provide
multiple physical and financial
platforms for the demise of
twentieth-century market democracy
atypical plans are architecture of the
not simply rectilinear any accumulation
of shapes makes them atypical even
squares there are products of a new
world where sites physical and financial
are made and not found at their best
they acquire a formless iconicity they
represent the point where the home
through sheer economic irrationality and
spatial inefficiency assumes an almost
mystical status atypical plans are
maximalism for the masses already latent
in the first exuberantly non-utilitarian
explorations by the end of the era of a
typical atypical plans ie now the
non-utilitarian is defined is refined as
a sensuous science of coordination
oversized columns massive multi-layered
facades coffered ceilings marble tiles
accent lighting luxurious bathroom
fixtures abundant electrical outlets
hardwood flooring artfully staged
furniture tasteful color schemes central
air conditioning they transcend the
practice to emerge in a rarefied
existential domain of guilt-free
subjectivity you can never only be in a
typical plans you can only act sleep eat
make love and hopefully refinance
atypical plans are deep wide and
sprawling they've evolved beyond the
naive humanist assumption that contact
with an exterior so-called reality is a
necessary condition for human happiness
for survival if that's true why build at
all and anyway aren't the disadvantages
of the exterior disadvantages which the
multiplication of atypical plans helped
produce ozone depleted carbo charged
globally heated by now well-established
mortgage-backed securities and mortgage
interest deductions which are the scene
akwonton of atypical plans impose a
regime of speculation of money that
defines invisible communities not quite
homogeneous segments of a market born
collective channel to be a complicated
calculus through real estate mortgage
investment conduits
heroic leader the Equalists architects
of atypical plants effortless
effortlessly delivered generic worlds of
pure ego atypical plans are American
there are no equivalents in any other
culture they are the residue of modern
capitalism itself in the ever-increasing
dimension from income to debt the hidden
potential of credit they proclaim the
superiority of the luxury of the
artificial to the poverty of the real
which remains whether admitted or not
the true credo of American civilization
the source of its universal attraction
atypical plans have learned what
architecture can never admit that the
coordination of matter the coordination
of matter and desire is the most as at
most postponed failure a temporary
rollback of the frontiers of economic
chaos atypical plans are not gridded not
absolute their rambling in elegance runs
counter to European platonic a
moralistic system meant system to
measure misfit and thus create
unhappiness on the contrary through the
development of anti ideological devices
a metaphysics of slack that gives an
aura of dignified authority to even the
most severely conflicted formal and
stylistic coexistence 'as they bestow
the appearance of decorous conquest on
the essentially messy reasserting
formality from the most compromised
Givens atypical plans are not neutral
but they are strangely anonymous there
are places of isolated worship more
voluminous than baroque churches they
provide infinitely greater space for
Cronk congregant private 20th century
chapels with a shared doctrine of
ever-increasing equity although the
dominant emphasis of a typical plans is
on representation there is plumbing
elaborately deployed rather than deny
those residual features that make humans
animals still they celebrate every bowel
movement every bath ingenious
architectural arrangements of miniature
symmetries and coordinated sight lines
organize the traffic the visual traffic
creating exalted realms that have
normally impure zones in the typical
atypical plan just as an example this
site line
down to your love pool now I've lost
myself these spaces master bathrooms
kitchens are the highly visible
sanctuaries for all those primitive
aspects upon which include upon whose
inclusion the correct unfolding of the
business of the pledge of pleasurable
domesticity depends these are also all
at the same scale atypical plans are to
the resident what the stage set is to
the actor their familiarity facilitates
performance event exchange appearance
disappearance failure success atypical
plans are relentlessly enabling
ennobling background atypical plans
demand repetition each instance is the
enth plan to be atypical there must be
many and articulated indeterminacy to be
atypical each must be conspicuously
undefined they require the presence of
many other somewhat similar plans but at
the same time suggest that each plan is
unique and that their exact number is of
no importance
atypical plans time n equals the
suburban metropolis but perhaps re not
hardly a reason to study architecture
but perhaps a reason to study economics
houses strung together by roads of
incomprehensible smoothness and
equations of incomprehensible complexity
each discrete welcome mat and wall treat
Wall Street transaction part of a
never-ending addition atypical plans
threaten the myth of the architect is
Demi our enlightened source of order and
discipline as in the scene of the crime
the removal of all signs of the
perpetrator characterizes the true
atypical plan its authors form an
avant-garde of her developers as erasers
it son song and unnamed designers
labouring anonymously for Toll Brothers
DR Horton kV home and a host of others
represent vanishing axes so successful
that as if they had never appeared these
architects transform comfort into luxury
creating aleatory playgrounds into
interior religion Fields accessible in
anyone's lifetime ie the American dream
in quantities trillions of acres that
are no longer on
imaginable securely entrenched in the
domain of Philistine ISM atypical plans
have obvious affinities with other
popular arts the sampling of familiar
yet distorted references has a
focus-grouped quality it is the
equivalent of manufactured pop music
serial television greeting card poetry
assembly line art it is architecture as
affirmation atypical plans at least you
get a little sort of eye candy with your
monotonous tone atypical plans are as
full as possible a floor level changes
of layered views of volume pressurizing
an irregular perimeter and of a maximum
of materials all other architecture is
about reason and consistency order and
security atypical plans are about
passion the soothing of our insecurities
architecture is monstrous in the way in
which choice leads to the reduction of
possibility it implies a regime of
either-or decisions often claustrophobic
even for the architect all other
architecture preempts the future
atypical plans by making any choice
viable denies it entirely along with any
real sense of the past keeping us
forever in the present the cumulative
effect of all this fullness this
systematic commitment to volume is
paradoxically low-density the typical
American city is a brute accumulation of
atypical plans a vast plane of
incrementally planned in determination
hollowness is filled could the spec
house be the most radical typology a
kind of Omni type defined by all the
qualities its occupants aspire to as the
most delivered program of the late
modern age its effect is totalizing
atypical plans are the latest mutation
in a chain that has revolutionized the
urban condition concentrations of
atypical plans have produced the
subdivision picturesque cluster
accumulations of subdivisions the only
new urban condition exurbs defined by
sheer quantity of low-density
high-calorie matter rather than as a
specific formal configuration the
periphery is now Universal in every
place defined by like-minded
indifference practically immune to local
variation atypical plans have made the
city unrecognizable an unidentifiable
object atypical plans are a quantum leap
that provokes a conceptual leap and
abundance of content in quantities that
overwhelm were simply preempt
intellectual speculation
what delusion triggered this broad
spread of atypical plans where did the
sprawl start was that they're very
apotheosis that turned houses into real
estate dwelling into gambling did plans
with surplus qualities create men with
outsized appetites were the spaces of
atypical plans the incubators of the
faithful followers of geeks bearing
formulas suddenly the actor blamed the
set for his lack of character
if typical planet comma dated in
conspicuous production atypical plans
celebrate conspicuous consumption they
make most houses into individual
trophies filling the city with the
alarming assertions of millions of
environmentally disconnected get
financially interdependent individual
mini Ecology's environments that
seemingly offered demanded little and
promised everything we're suddenly seen
as infernal machines for stripping
identity and wealth Tony Robbins lost
out to economics 101 in modern
architecture there are only typical
plans in the teens and 20s architects
fantasized about dwellings in 1914 Korb
imagined the ultimate typical plan with
the Maison Domino in 29 Ginsberg built
the first dwelling slab for Moscow a
communal house for workers it's
rectangles conceived as a socialist
prototypical plan two perpendicular
blocks introduced the workers to the
full paraphernalia of a new collective
domestic life a communal dining hall a
sports hall a library transitional
living units to create an expanded
experimental super house of Soviet
lifestyle in 67 Moshe Safdie deployed
typical plans in Montreal as a terminal
dwelling condition of Western
civilization a utopian mountain of
normalized modules since then the one
architectural subject the 20th century
delivered on mass has been endlessly
denigrated in name of ideology its
occupants slaves its environment
faceless its accumulations ugly
architecture has suffered from a
catastrophic failure to participate in
the production of to perform the one
typology whose proliferation was
economically and urbanistic alee
inevitable atypical plans have been
condemned to the status of a cancer
devouring larger and larger sections of
land invading whole ecologies no longer
only exiled to the periphery they
returned with the vengeance to consume
the city itself for houses America
multiplies typical plans a typically
using a model known since the
Renaissance the aristocratic palace or
manor house is there a connector
connection between the notorious
individualism of the American population
and its sacred cow the detached private
residence the American House is fat as
fat as its ground breaking cumulative
substance is thin the American needs
status and space even though a simple
extrapolation of the square feet
involved reveals that this need will
destroy the very resources that reassure
him of his manifest destiny where the
European minimum dwelling assembles a
critical mass the American house
inflates it simply because things that
happen in a house are supposed to be
good and we like our goodness in very
big doses there is something almost
insane in masochistic about the quantity
and utterly inferior ease inferior
substance that is generated in the new
world in the name of achievement if
typical plans promise the dream of a
mass-produced collective dwelling a
typical plans deliver the reality of a
mask customized collective debt and
we're almost for almost a freedom land
actually thank God this is the beginning
of freedom land although the end of
freedom land looks nothing like it when
I wrote this piece for perspective or
should I say when I when I plagiarized
Rem Koolhaas for perspective I started
to do a drawing I wanted to have a
drawing that would go with it and they
wouldn't let me run all those plans
along the bottom because of some
copyright thing so I started actually
just budding up these plans that I've
been collecting to see what kind of
organizations could be produced what
would it spark in some way and really
you know treating it super graphically
but with my obsession with the smiths
ins and team tan and matte buildings
like what if you had a matte suburb
some way so it began sort of innocently
enough with me playing with plans but
now I'd like to talk briefly about
freedom land I'm guessing it maybe had
like 10 minutes boom okay it's this
internal clock of fatherhood that works
really well so I'd like to close with
the project I'm currently working on
still in a gestational stage freedom
land is a scheme for a new settlement
new settlement model situated
comfortably within the super grid that
defines much of America constructed
using the most eminently American of
building blocks a single-family house
it's logic is one of both and both
Jefferson and Hamilton founding fathers
of our collective split personality both
open and closed both centralized and
decentralized both individualistic and
collectivist both farm and market both
local and global both village and villa
and ultimately both city and country so
here's the beginning of the end of the
talk I'll be reading from a text for
this project which will be a company the
project in 30-60-90 this is not freedom
land although it looks a lot like
freedom land in his discourse concerning
this is a title in his discourse
concerning the designed establishment of
a new colony to the south of Carolina in
the most delightful country of the
universe Robert Montgomery an Englishman
describes his plans for a new colony the
margrove 8 of Azealia in an area that is
now Georgia never having set foot in
North America at the time but still with
great confidence the confidence of a of
a David Weekley he began his description
for the Marga bait as follows quote
neither would we have thought at a labor
so tedious as tis generally fancied to
establish in this manner a colony which
may become not only an advantage but a
glory to the nation we have prospects
before us most attractive and
unprecedented in the three tempting
points wealth safety and Liberty
benefits like these can never fail of
drawing numbers of inhabitants from
every corner and men once got together
tis
easy to dispose of them regularly and
with due regard to order beauty and the
comforts of society as to leave them to
the folly of fixing at random and
destroying their interest by indulging
their humour so that we have more than
ordinary cause to expect that in a very
short time we should be able to present
the solid life itself as now we give the
shadow only in the following explanation
I thought that was a really good way to
start something so I just used it to
start Freedomland and with that let me
begin what I wrote
having been requested by the editors and
required by the times to draw up a
detailed plan for the general
improvement of American housing in the
aftermath of the great financial crisis
and its effect upon our collective
confidence in the correctness of our
living living patterns I humbly submit
the following proposal we begin our
description as did Sir Robert Montgomery
in describing his fabled proposal for
the margarita vasilia
you must suppose a level dry and
fruitful tract of land in some fine
plain or Valley that having been
surveyed as part of the great parceling
of America according to the method set
forth in the land ordinance of 1785 is
continuously gridded into square
townships of six miles per side each
containing 36 one square miles sections
of 640 acres so this is one of the
original townships which most of the
country is subdivided into so
Freedomland
here you're getting a glimpse of four
townships which produces in Freedomland
eight settlements and eight preserves I
like to think of them as hunting grounds
something very aristocratic this grid
the framework for mr. Thomas Jefferson's
vision of a rural Democratic Society of
citizen farmers but also a great game
board of rampant real-estate speculation
provides the underlying structure
structure for freedom land a new
settlement model that reconciles
resurgent dreams for an agrarian
urbanism with long habituated domestic
appetites it now being fully established
by learned people and increasingly
acknowledged by lay persons that our
current settlement patterns are both
unlovely and unsustainable freedom land
is premise then on the following
irrefutable truths that local farming is
good being that it provides better food
and makes better use of our limit
increasingly limited resources than
commercial agriculture that urban living
is also good improving as it does the
health happiness and prosperity of the
people and that the majority of
Americans the veracity of the above
notwithstanding still aspire to the
material and spatial luxuries
represented by the detached
single-family house as it is most
resplendent Lee found in the suburbs the
plan of freedom land results from the
subdivision of a typical survey Township
into four equal squares three miles to
aside so that's three by three the
northwest and southeast quadrants are
established as new towns and further
subdivided to forms 36 square sections
of 160 acres each there's one excepting
that area dedicated to the town's
primary roads which divide them at
intervals of one-half mile as in the
original survey townships these sections
are numbered beginning with the number
one in the northeast corner and
proceeding west and east ultimately
through the township with progressive
numbers until the 36 be completed the
two remaining quadrants are preserved in
or if necessary restored to their
natural state as unencumbered retreats
for the pleasure of the townspeople so
pleasure one survey Township divided to
form two towns and two natural preserves
is the absolute minimum area are
necessary for the establishment of
freedom land if this plan is aggregated
to form a group larger than a single 36
mile survey Township and a checkerboard
layout results and will just go back
checkerboard
in a like manner to that proposed by mr.
Thomas Jefferson producing at the grand
scale an alternating arrangement of town
and country there is no maximum limit to
such an aggregation except for any
geographical or political obstacles that
may arise to thwart the just and proper
extension of the settlement by its
people
one town the four sections at the center
of each town are occupied by a Civic
core comprised the infrastructure
necessary to the maintenance and
preservation of the community whereas
the original land ordinance reserved
section 16 that's section 16 here
actually you can just follow the chart
for the use of Education in freedom land
it being recognized that the choices of
means and methods of education they're
best left to individual families the
central squares are rightly devoted to
more pressing and universal needs the
waist square and ever-growing manicured
pyramid of refuse rises slowly in
Section 16 the water square a circle
your circular reservoir nearly one-half
mile in diameter occupies section 15 the
energy square of forest of 20 by 20 foot
solar panels occupy powers the town from
section 21 here and the supply square a
big box store covering 10 acres at the
center of section 22 provides access to
those products and services which are
not produced through the prodigious
industry of the townspeople now we're
going to zoom in on the lower right or
the southeast quad there's the town
center big box
parking playing fields all your
community needs how many of your
community needs big you know big
community not small local community the
32 remaining sections are quartered by
roads secondary to those above-mentioned
to form four equal parts of 40 acres
less the dimension of the roads by which
they're divided and served 128
individual neighborhood farm estates so
here you're seeing one quarter of that
each an independent self-governing
community are further subdivided into
four ten acre squares of which three are
dedicated to agricultural pursuits while
the remaining two while the dwellings
are located on the fourth in this manner
fully three-quarters of every town in
freedom land shall remain open green and
free of unsightly structures so this is
1a state 3
sort of agricultural quads and one
dwelling quad I'll zoom in a little bit
more if you get a better view of that it
being well known that people by their
very nature equally desirous the
pleasures of novelty is their needful of
the comforts of familiarity Freedomland
seeks to offer both in due time after
the passing of twenty years and in a
manner similar to crop rotation the
entire estate including the dwellings
which are dismantled and rebuilt rotates
counterclockwise completing a full
rotation every 80 years one life this
has the positive effect of producing of
providing each resident at regular
intervals with a new home that is
exactly the same as their old home as
each of state rotates this has the
further beneficial consequence of
producing an ever-changing prospect of
built and open space throughout the town
so you can imagine these are all
rotating you also you're always getting
new neighbor new neighboring estates
well not you know every 20 years it's a
long time to wait but it's ok and we'll
zoom now in on a couple of the estates
so each neighborhood estate and
Freedomland is comprised of between 8
and 60 houses all those within any
particular state being one just like the
next and in this manner ensuring a
cohesiveness of identity and a
consistency of character such that
property values are protected and a
sense of community and neighborliness is
promoted whereas architects have proven
themselves disinclined or perhaps just
ill prepared to deliver designs desired
by a majority of the American people the
houses in freedom land are built
according to the designs careful designs
carefully selected from among the best
produced by the country's greatest
builders designs that have proven to be
highly popular with people possessed of
the most discriminating taste and
therefore certain to attract the finest
type of citizen so this estate is built
from this plan which looks to me like a
David Weekley plan this is a David
Weekley plan you saw this earlier so
that is clustered to produce this sort
of you know super
kind of an a vague leader a kind of
footprint here with this massive super
court in the middle here's another this
is also David Weekley plant I have I'm
become like a one of David weeklies
biggest fans I have a poster in my
bedroom depending upon the number of
houses in the particular manner in which
they are arranged a neighborhood of
houses may take on the character of
either a large villa or a small village
families are thus able to select the
estate that most closely matches their
spatial stylistic and consequently
social preferences thereby affording
them a life among like-minded neighbors
with a shared sense of duty and purpose
go through another one this is a Toll
Brothers this is this monstrous Toll
Brothers plant the other thing you can
see from these plans this plan I
actually probably know but definitely in
Arizona or the southwest you can start
to read these plans if you spend too
much time looking at them read sort of
reached regionally specific traits in
them anyways so this starts to produce a
sort of denser matte with these small
courts and I'm being really kind of I
guess slightly snarky about this but as
I started doing this actually started
seeing potential in these these
clustering arrangements and a kind of
Liberty in not designing a cell but
designing this sort of the aggregation
and then actually like what what I
started to see was a lack of
particularly in this kind of plan it's
hard to actually find the original house
and you actually just see rooms upon
rooms upon rooms and begin to imagine
and that's the next phase of the project
is to kind of inhabit this here's
another one and some of the operations
the operations are very simple rotation
reflection a garage always has to be
accessible a front door doesn't always
have to be accessible so front doors can
but other front doors which produces
very kind of you know ice storm key
party arrangements
so it's it's it's hoped that in this
description concise that may be
sufficient to describe the sublime
structure of Freedomland its natural and
rightful connection to the foundational
principles of our great country and its
superiority to other modes of settlement
and I'm just going to go through these
as I finish I've already come clean
frankly but so it's Freedomland I was
asked by the editors of 30-60-90 to do
something design a house write an essay
something that addressed the housing
crisis and a lot of people were
designing single-family houses as you
know that was how to respond to the
housing crisis which I have to say I
thought was kind of absurd that you know
another house is gonna solve this
problem so I decided that I'd attempt to
make something out of the houses I'd
been looking at and thinking about so I
decided to stop tinkering and analyzing
and to play the visionary to make a
grand absurdist move that would like the
work of a benevolent or perhaps
delusional dictator try to please
everyone to accommodate every wish every
desire no matter how contradictory and
to combine them in a master plan that
sets out a beautiful naive version for a
better and more harmonious world in
freedom land then the American Dream
battered by even if ultimately
responsible for the recent economic
events confronts the reality of
increasingly scarce resources Tea Party
populism meets Green Party academics ISM
the landscape or are they now agrarian
urbanist community Muniz omim filtrates
capitalism consumerist single-family
houses construct communist communalist
philanthropy odoo speeds global markets
and Hamilton central authority
reconciles with Jefferson citizen farmer
however unlike the beneficent beneficent
vision of a kindly authoritarian leader
I was under no illusion that freedom
land would please its constituents it's
a fiction the satire with no pretence
towards implementation it's both
perfectly rational so the core the core
I hope Michelle doesn't actually make me
really run the numbers but approximately
actually is enough to service all of
that so you know it works
depending on where it is depending on
where it is but it's in a fine and
pleasant valley we already established
that so so it's perfectly rational and
patently absurd but in the absurdity
lies a realm of opportunity as in the
best satire stones are thrown not with
malice both great affection and with
hope thank you
because you know that satire is what
closes on Saturday night I know but
luckily I'm not a professional satirist
good I'm sure there are some questions
from people in the audience Peter an
hour and six minutes you have a question
Peter he's taking your analysis course I
don't want Peters the critique of my
drawings or the students for that matter
Becky gamer has a question she's in
front that's professor gamer this of the
oh my god of the Builder houses is there
absurd perimeter and that's part of the
eight typicality and so that absurd
perimeter then also makes bizarre
outdoor spaces which we can think of as
porches or whatever but the quality of
those outdoor space it the plight of
outdoor spaces we would be a potential
way to think about the accumulation of
these buildings not just how they attach
to each other in a neutral field but how
those outdoor spaces imply a semi-public
of public semi-private so you choose the
opposite rule which is to put these
accumulated things in a neutral square
perimeters such that we can see semi
green dark green and whatever is as a
way of modulating what those outdoor
spaces are but I'm wondering whether one
could now actually start with the house
and see what their exterior spaces imply
because it would be starting when you
get to freedom land would be like
starting with the houses themselves and
really thinking through how they then
make not just attachments but outdoor
spaces as opposed to putting it into an
int neutral grid I'm I'm just I think
you see this is not a great one but on
some of them internally you see what
you're talking about
you know I like this a little bit but I
know but there are and there's like
crazy series of drawings but where these
are actually begin to either not
directly a but but sort of rub up close
to other aggregations to produce denser
fields or and frankly like with a
sprawling one at different scales I was
actually looking more at the space
between than I was at clearly that one
doesn't have a legible figure right in
the plan this I mean this was definitely
a kind of I've been working on the
aggregations and then I got this request
and I was so surprised by the you know
like design a house we've had this
terrible housing crisis design house and
so like I want it to be as provocative
as possible right with this for its
where it was being delivered right I
asked this partly because the utopianist
of this is of interest to me and in the
utopian plans that we we've looked at in
in the seminar the majority start with
the big grand plan and then you come
down to the community and the
neighborhood in the block and you come
down to the house but some actually
start with the house and then build up
its implications from the house really
how do you live and then what does that
mean for the street what does it mean
since you're starting with a house in
your research that's my question is why
could you possibly just start with the
house as opposed to after doing that
starting with the big community the big
grid and then going smaller and smaller
move in the other direction I I think
it's definitely a step to take with this
and it's a step that exists in you know
I was gonna say on trace but I don't
have trace on files on my damaged hard
drive but that that is and these do
start it's you know that starts with
this but it also with the knowledge that
it exists within this other rhetorical
framework really more than than anything
else which is the grid and is the you
know the wanting like from the very
beginning like how do I make a village
in a villa how do I you know sort of
give you your house
you know your single-family detached
grand formal Toll Brothers house feel
like Joel might do that and and also you
know give you your happy you know new
urbanist little community of 30 or 40
people who share your faith Keller I
said just questions that are just
curiosities given that you've been out
in the field
I'm just curious with the weekly
brothers weekly Toll Brothers are pretty
good so you so you you you buy a house
what are the site logistics I mean how
is it different from kind of the
mid-century side as as assembly-line
what happens with the multiples of
houses that's my first question and you
could answer you through one of these
and the second question is what is the
status of the mancave and what who made
that up is that is that is that you know
it in your in your fieldwork have you
discovered I I have not the first time I
heard mancave was Luke Bowman showing me
his mancave that sounds terrible but you
know
I thought the man cave began with a
cro-magnon man it's a thing there are so
so many weird there's like a lot of
weird little sidebar stories in doing
this research so you know man cave or
the hog pen
anyone guess what a hog pen is and in a
house and during the boom its place to
park your hog your motorcycle but it
actually like literally a space in these
and then there's all sorts of versions
of old rooms coming back the keeping
room you know folding those back in as
the houses got bigger they had to you
couldn't just keep putting flex-space in
every extra cell that you added on to
your house and also because actually you
know the profits increased when houses
were selling along a pretty steep curve
versus cost as the houses drew you know
so you know you're getting a little bit
more for every additional square foot
over a kind of baseline but the mancave
I don't I don't know where it started
the other question how do they deal with
site logistics a lot of the companies
now and I think including weekly
actually have factories that are
producing or they were the ones that are
still operating factory that that were
producing components and they're just so
sort of streamlined in terms of their
logistical structure that they can do a
factory built like you know a kind of
Leavitt factory bit rollout thing but on
a site by site scattered lot basis they
still they still do but actually
typically the builders are not the ones
doing the subdividing of land or
developers at subdivide land and so a
lot of subdivisions will have like David
Weekley and KB home and somebody else
doing parts of this subdivision rather
than because they they don't want to be
in that kind of land game if they can
avoid it or they don't want to be in it
until that sites are ready so when a
developer does it the sites are ready
and they're actually buying a site ready
to build but they also do all the
companies have built on your lot program
so you can go in there and if you bought
a lot in New Haven
pick a house if it would fit on the New
Haven lot and they would build it for
you I mean it there's probably something
around here it would do that Emanuel Oh
God
well I I really loved your last part of
the presentation and I hate the first
part of the presentation I think you for
the reason that in the last part you
really appear as an architect I am even
shocked to see that we have a new
Ricardo Bofill on the faculty but it's
it's interesting but the your analysis
has in a way strictly nothing to do with
your proposal in the sense that the
processes of production that leads to
the buildings that you analyze the newer
that you analyze are completely
different from the processes of
production of your Freedomland in the
sense that here you appear as an
architect you posit certain overall
forms and you fill these rooms in that
you claim come from your analysis of
desire of Suburbia but you know really
these rooms don't matter in your scheme
because what matters is the symmetry the
internal gardens you know the form that
the architect willed into existence not
the capitalist cancerous growth that you
claimed was interesting in your first
half of the talk luckily that's not a
question
I don't think that was a quote was a
comment that was a comment and therefore
I feel no need to respond
except maybe over drinks at least he
liked part of it yeah are there any more
it's a nice way oh that I made a min
you'll suffer for 50 minutes are there
questions or comments yes
Dolores wait a second Mike will be
passed across to you well Keith you're
working in a very long American
tradition of people who thought that
they could sketch out the ideal
political and social system on the
landscape but you are working in the
smaller part of that tradition which is
the satirical part rather than the
idealistic part I think and I wonder if
you could tell us more about how you
understand your audience and are you
thinking that the audience is primarily
architects or are you thinking that
there are ways to show the Freedomland
project to Americans overall to create a
certain amount of commentary and
engagement it's that's a great question
and one time Allen Platt is to ask me
Steve what are you gonna do when someone
calls you up and says I want one
you know like what I mean probably that
would just be like half of this or
something
and I don't know the answer yet Dolores
and I know the history that you're
talking about and in fact like I there's
a longer version of this where it
actually cops to its precedence some of
which are ones that I became aware of
through your utopias book and I think
the satire it's it it somehow lets me
keep working right now without like
prejudging the results but like for me
when I actually get down this is maybe
not a great version but in some of these
when I actually get down to the scale of
the estate there are some really
exciting things happening in terms of
the new types of associations it makes
either through the exterior spaces or
even the both feel less things that that
Emanuel astutely identified at the at
the bigger scale it is is 80 percent
satire and up to at the estate scale
it's 65 percent you know kind of
idealistic maybe and and I'm still
grappling with you know these are when I
started looking at this stuff I was sure
like like probably most architects are
that you know when the builders say
we're just giving the people what they
want that they're full of [ __ ]
and now after looking at it you know I
can see that the builders are in fact
construct obviously constructing taste
and construction desires but now that
those things have been constructed and
they're constructed long before David
Weekley was born they are something that
we have to grapple with even in this new
climate politically and economically and
this is the beginning of trying to to do
that in some way but I don't like it
exists as satire right now because it
lets me forestall certainty and closure
if that makes any sense
makes sense to me well maybe I would
just say do you think that you want
people to have a stylistic criticism
which would be the first part of your
talk about how we can make fun of what's
in those model houses and the lifestyles
that are symbolized by certain objects
or certain placements of walls or hot
tubs or do you want it to be a political
criticism which would have to cut into
the question about public policy the
marketing of well public policy in the
way that subsidies for housing have been
developed in the 20th century that is a
complex question that a lot of people
would be well-advised to understand and
I'm sure you know about also easily
easily separated from one another
because that the desires that are that
those model homes are playing to and and
you know playing to and creating our
desires have become politicized and that
maintain structures that the structures
that you're talking about so because
those attachments are formed and it's
why we still you know put money as a
society in certain places and don't put
it in other places well I don't think
that consumers are running things I'm
not saying they're running thing but the
you know people buying these houses are
voters I would guess and you know and
they're living in places that that tend
to go in certain directions politically
so I don't know that at least for me
like to detach one thing from the others
is hard to do I know what you're talking
about and I benefit as an urban dweller
I benefit from the subsidies to you know
mortgage interest deduction benefits me
you know incredibly and I hope like I
was kind of in awe of I mean I've a
little bit like you know why does this
make me uncomfortable but also in awe of
how seamless those model homes were laid
out I mean there's like top to bottom
soup to nuts you know it tells a story
and it's a story that you know is
appealing to not just you know
you know like to parent you know to
point to children you know white
families there are all sorts of people
were in that model home place you know
like really sort of absorbed in what and
what they were taking in admit so maybe
all we need to have the mic hold on and
then and then Joel I think that's what
he put his hand up to weigh in you
didn't you he did you did well I'll give
you a chance there's a kind of reversal
actually contradict the manual as I
often like to do that the first things
to me seem to be within the realm of the
disciplines that architecture is
interested namely property and clear
identity of the parts but when they're
assembled there isn't actually property
in any of these plans there isn't Lots
associated with any of the units
especially in this one it's one of the
cases you don't know where that green
space ends are really where the unit end
so they start to erase I would say
conventions of architecture in that way
and so you sort of hinted at the
occupation of these things would be the
next form of interrogation where any
kind of subjectivity associated even in
a characteristic way with the developer
house gets erased somehow and though in
formalism of the plants in all senses do
you really intend to go that far with
that in terms of that that part of the
interrogation of this work that sort of
comes out of a process and actually
challenge the beard symmetries and
things like that are sort of conventions
of standard architectural cliche saying
to actually get into the what do you
mean by that I think there's something
to that how do you actually occupy these
things do you occupy them counter to
their they're scripted out well one
thing that it's all heritage I feel a
little bit like a like a preschooler
sometimes working on this but like you
put two front doors because there's only
a rule that you have to get to the
garage which is like it you know
whatever it's a rule but so that means
you get like you know this faceoff where
two things I don't know if it's
happening here probably some places abut
and all of a sudden that when those two
front doors
the whole structure internal structure
of the house gets you can't see it in
the same way any longer right because
you lose the almost all of these houses
regardless of how informally how the
front door is the front door no matter
how little used it is so when that when
that happens like all the wiring changes
and so for me that's part of the step in
doing these also when the yard you know
when they implied like you're talking
about when the implied boundary of the
lot disappears and you can no longer
actually understand where that offset is
right five or ten feet on the side of 20
or 25 feet in the front and back that
also rewires first in the cm thing is to
examine property and erase it but what's
funny in addition like it Keller and I
figure this like a lot of things that
are happening here I mean this scale no
but at other scales the builders are
already doing it there's one I found I
never want to show it because I want to
feel more original but where they
literally took the four houses and
didn't like a Frank Lloyd Wright
pinwheel on them so they they had no
back yards anymore they just had front
yards it's kind of mind-blowing right it
takes this thing that just looks like
kind of crap and makes it like whoa so
they're already experimenting because
they're scratching it out I mean they're
really scratching out that I do think
that graph I showed the beginning is
kind of funny like they're you know
really careful now but where they were
investing money when they were throwing
money around KB home was like April
crimen was doing there and it were
reports and there were hundreds of pages
long and you know also and now it's like
two-page letter to shareholders and then
that and then that the sec form and
that's it and tiny little and the other
thing these houses fewer and fewer of
these crazy ones are being done now that
one's there all you really should be
careful what you wish for sometimes
because they're all now going back to
plans that are really close to being
true Levittown plans except they're
selling him as the mid-century modern
like they're playing that whole game and
like Shea Holmes is doing this thing
where instead of like dining room
they'll say like eat and in bedroom
it'll say
you know sleep or master-bedroom it says
dream and and they're built you know and
and like everything is stripped out
there's no poche in the plans like
there's no if you see photographs of it
there's no detail anymore you know not
that I want to have crown molding in my
house but they're stripping these down
and actually building and what the role
of wainscotting I would like but set
like your ability they're all building
Foursquare and laminar houses now Joe
would you like to add anything to this
and yours will be the last if you're
feeling that you're being interrogated
by every member of our faculty I want to
begin by saying how much I appreciated
your delivering such a thought-provoking
provocative and and dare I say
unsettling disturbing in a really good
way lecture which i think is a very hard
thing to to pull off and so I guess my
question is no not just a question but
also you delivered on your promise to
kind of come clean with your
self-described obsession with with
suburbia and suburban plants but I guess
my question is an obvious one in your
introduction you give this very poetic
ellic eloquent sort of description of
the way in which you know every
scenographic prop and piece of interior
decoration is a kind of signifier of
identity and different identities in the
house and I expected you to continue
that kind of reading in your discussion
of the plans which what you didn't but
most importantly I which is not a
criticism but what I was but that's what
I expected but instead okay there was a
conspicuous absence of what's obvious of
any section of an elevation so I guess
my question is kind of why and does your
kind of obsession with planned porn ever
extent to elevations elevation bar and
elevation and sexual porn and if if not
why not
elevations are easy to get a hold of
elevations for these things are easy to
get a hold of as easy as the plans which
are really really easy to get a hold it
like go to the websites you know not
that anyone wants to do it but or maybe
I'll start selling
you know little flash drives of them and
the elevations are there too in most
cases drawn elevations often renderings
sections that don't have so sections
would necessarily be constructed but I
guess one reason to point that part the
plans for me is because the the image of
the house and I think I did a pretty
good job of not showing any images of
houses except maybe one is like we all
feel like well we know that thing and if
you show them like even though they're
different they look alike they tend to
read alike and so just focusing on the
plans for this even for the first part
which is about this the set decoration
and the life styling of the houses
rather than you know showing photographs
either at the real thing or stand-in
photographs was to try to really just
look at them as organizations right and
they use the plans and also because the
builders tend to surprisingly enough use
the plans to sell these houses it's kind
of amazing like you go to the website
and it's like this house in this
neighborhood
view the plan not view the elevation or
view a photograph view the plan and then
from there it's take a tour so those two
reasons the other thing about the
symmetries and the sight lines and those
are given the ground I wanted to cover
to set up freedom land tonight like
those are other aspects of the research
I've been doing like this sort of the
parts of the plan that are really about
constructing lifestyle rather than the
underlying topologies of that so like
like in your reading actually prescribed
and facilitate and construct lifestyle
or does it as you sometimes need to
suggest that it's it's a completely kind
of arbitrary relationship let's say
between sign and signifiers and and it
could be absolutely interchangeable and
just a proliferation of a kind of pure
nazy and collage I kept on oscillating
back and forth during your whole lecture
with that question in my mind
which I think it's an amazingly
interesting question I think so too can
I can I have a drink ginger we all think
it's an interesting question to carry
forward thank our speaker go upstairs
and have a drink